oh we have been following during our
live streams not so much during the
podcast but during our live streams this
trucker convoy
in canada which has been um i don't even
really want to call it organizing
they've sort of been demonstrating by
blocking roads and
honking horns
against vaccine mandates
heavily related to provincial canadian
government decisions and now the big
thing is that the canadian truckers are
going to come to the us along with
american truckers in order to protest
joe biden's vaccine mandates and of
course the problem with that is
there really are no such mandates the
the supreme court blocked the biden
mandate so we're going to get to that
but there are people including tucker
carlson who are now rand paul is another
they are starting to lionize these
truckers
as uh heroic freedom fighters against uh
biden's oppressive you know whatever
let's take a listen to tucker here
telling us what's gonna be happening
and in that vein tonight a group of
american truckers announced they will
begin a nationwide truck convoy in this
country starting next month
in protest against joe biden's vaccine
mandates right now the problem is that
joe biden's vaccine mandates essentially
do not exist
i mean it's you know it's sort of like
we must protest against the american
lockdowns right what you mean sometimes
people wear masks what lockdowns are you
talking about the supreme court blocked
the biden vaccine mandate for employers
with more than 100 employees in january
it's done
there is no such mandate
not to mention
that it wasn't even really a mandate in
that anybody who didn't want to be
vaccinated could just test instead and
only once a week not once a day the way
fox news is much stricter requirement uh
put in place
states
are responsible
for implementing their own vaccine
requirements as they so please different
states have put in place different rules
and as a reminder the requirements for
crossing the border you know a big thing
with truckers is oh
we you got to be vaccinated to go to
canada or to come back from canada
whatever um
this is
number one applying in many countries
and it's applying in both directions so
the idea of protesting
biden's
vaccine mandates
is bogus and bizarre this is not really
about vaccine mandates first and
foremost it's about once again
similarly to
the trump riots and trump's threats for
mass protests and all these things it's
about generating unrest which they
believe they can use to their advantage
and there's a few different ways in
which they might do that which we'll
talk about later this week
the other important aspect of this
american truck convoy
that is as usual hypocritical and and
deceptive is
the very same people
blaming biden for the supply chain
issues which are really global supply
chain issues that need to be fixed of
course but they're blaming biden for
them
they are going to do something which
will at least in principle make those
supply and supply chain issues worse
it is not the mandates
that are making the supply chain issues
a problem
there are global economic realities that
are having that impact but
taking all of these truckers who
themselves are responsible for moving
product around and not only taking them
off the road moving product but also
blocking roads
and bridges or whatever they plan to do
that's going to make it more difficult
to move products around the united
states they are going to make worse the
very problem that they are blaming joe
biden for so it doesn't have to do with
vaccine mandates obviously if you
couldn't tell and also remember the
hypocrisy that they claim to be all
about law and order and yet they are
encouraging blocking roads which is
against the law and we can have our
views you know it's a completely
legitimate
uh perspective to defend
that when it is time to
make an impact you don't protest in the
ways that make everybody comfortable
part of
uh
civil disobedience long history of this
is well you're going to do things that
are going to make people uncomfortable
so that they pay attention to you i get
that but what was their view of antifa
blocking roads or black lives matter
blocking roads they were all about law
and order then
and now all of a sudden breaking the law
is justified to protest non-existent
mandates that they claim to be
protesting against so the real concern
at the end of the day is is this going
to lead to more violence and more
insanity in canada although there was a
smattering of white nationalism
anti-semitism and xenophobia within
these protests they were mostly what we
would generally describe as peaceful in
the united states i worry that they
won't be and donald trump's continued
escalating rhetoric about we're going to
protest this and the biggest protests
ever in all of this kind of coded
language about protests i'm worried
about what's going to happen next month
uh we will be following it and i'm
curious to hear from you let me know at
d pakman what do you expect as far as
this american version of the canadian
truck convoy uh is concerned what do you
expect to see
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too and for a limited time
chili sleep has a special offer just for
my audience go to chilisleep.com
pacman to learn about the exclusive
discount the link is down below